[Musique]
cynique six autres personnes et d'abus
sexuels et de violences sur quatre
garçons tous quatre années de fratries
différentes nous sommes importantes
passées ces sujets-là ateliers oui oui
parce que ben ça permet aux gens de lui
dire qu'il ce poste
mais non parce que ça peut effrayer les
gens ça peut être choquant pour les
enfants qui tu vois ça mais je pense que
il faut quand même en parler
le passager dire quatre coups de feu
avec un fusil de chasse de petit calibre
sept jeunes âgés de 16 à 20 ans sont
blessés dont un grièvement
qu'est ce que tu aurais voulu voir des
choses où l'ue ne pas prendre les choses
un sujet sur l'essence machines et les
le banc fracturée c'est important pour
construire et pour cause visualise bien
en tête que c'est grave ce qui vient de
se passer à 3 3 par le droit
le père de famille n'a rien oublié de
cette soirée du 13 novembre 2015
oui des fois il en prend un peu trop ça
se passe tous les jours des trucs comme
ça donc on pourrait en parler pendant
des années ça sert à rien de tout le
temps regardez ce qui se passe mais les
trucs importants comme les attentats et
bah c'est vraiment important
j'aime bien découvrir les choses parce
que ça peut nous arriver à nous donc
j'aime bien être informé en fait
[Musique]